this is like a very mixed look sometimes
the show looks like everyone's just
going to a showbiz funeral tonight it's
very mixed thank you very much
what you I've never seen you look that
smart before your life no I I thought
I'd make an effort because last time I
was on here was the the month before has
voted GQ second worst dressed man in the
world described me they do they do a
little feature in that a picture of me
they describe my look as an update on
Bilbo Baggins historical figure lovely
to have you back in the world blinking
into the lights after your year away
what do you see for us tonight cast
along the hill movie gold about it more
in a bit but I saw a clip you were in
accepting an award for for gold and
there was a really funny audience
reaction do you know what I'm talking
about I think I do
so you get up there you you get the
prize yeah and I see as I like to open
up I start off usually I start off with
all right of some sort all right all
right all right over three four three
words ever set on film and I think I
don't think about it but I think this
and I just said all right so anyone so
you can't say one all right you've got
to do three if it starts with one of it
I've got it like Bo Troost appears
something nice happen all right all
right all right
[Applause]
[Music]
you